erin is it your goal to create something
every day that's a good question it
i wouldn't say it's my goal to create
something every day but it's definitely
my goal to be working on something maybe
that i've already created every day
um i think it's really important to you
know flex that muscle constantly
um when i met victoria my producing
partner and girlfriend
it was actually her instagram
uh bio that said create every damn day
and i remember really liking that
did creating become a daily habit for
you or working on something
become a daily habit for you after you
saw victoria's instagram
or or that was just always in you anyway
and you're like yeah i get that
i i think it was the latter i think i
think i
i've always been
i've always wanted to create constantly
and
i think having a partner having someone
to do that with definitely
inspires me and like pushes me to
actually
follow through in what i promise myself
to do
i think it's it's easy to get lazy
sometimes
and uh
you know having someone right there by
your side saying we have to finish this
is a good sort of kick in the butt to
actually do it
um but it's definitely you know
inspiring and helpful having someone
with you
what are some of the things that stop
you from
creating or working on something every
day
this week i would say moving i didn't
really do much creating this week
although we did actually release a
making of
video for one of our little horror
shorts um
sometimes when i'm writing
especially if i'm writing a screenplay i
i do try to schedule
a block of the day to actually work on
writing uh if if i'm not feeling
particularly inspired it does help to
sort of take a break from that project
and move to something else
but there's never really a time in my
life where i'm
completely unable to work or
you know create something or work on a
project i already have going on i try to
do a little bit every day
some days are way more productive than
others though
is that your style anyway are you fairly
disciplined
i am pretty disciplined i've been called
a robot before
um not always in in the best way but uh
yeah you know i i wake up i i work out
i
pretty much have the same breakfast
every morning um
and then you know with my with my cup of
coffee i sit at my desk and i just work
uh and that'll be either writing or
editing
um and if i'm not here at home then i'll
be you know on set putting together a
movie or
a short film with friends
do you find safety in routine i know
some people who are the opposite where
they will go absolutely crazy if they
have to do the same thing but some
people i think crave
that routine
i think it helps to have some sort of
routine and discipline
but i i do always find my life and my my
attitude towards things to be somewhat
paradoxical
in that it helps to have a routine
but
you also have to be willing to break
that routine
it's i i think i think uh i can't even
believe i'm quoting bruce lee but i
think he said something about acting or
fighting
uh
where
you have to kind of learn everything
about
your craft and only then can you break
the rules
so i think i apply that on some level
what are 10 things an aspiring writer
should know about writing ten things yes
number one get a good cup of coffee
sorry
that yeah yeah like could we count that
as one
um
so so ten things that any writer should
know about writing
i think i think definitely definitely uh
staying caffeinated certainly helps
um i think
experience is is sort of an obvious one
i think
in film school i i found that
a lot of people were making movies about
things that they
knew nothing about
and that sort of bothered me i was
always at least in as an undergrad i
didn't really have much life experience
and so i was making
uh movies for better or worse sometimes
without as much substance but it was
still my experience
so i think experience is is a big one
um
i think discipline
and routine
being uh honest with yourself so honesty
is a big one
oh why sorry to interrupt but why that
one that's really good
i think honesty is really important to
writing because i didn't really even
start to realize that i was becoming
somewhat of a decent writer until i was
really honest with myself not just you
know
honesty in the sense of
you know digging deep in your heart and
telling your story or anything like that
but more so being honest about your work
trying to be objective looking at it and
sort of knowing deep down or at least
telling yourself deep down what you
really think of your work your writing
or your creation
i sort of found myself i don't want to
say lying to myself but i would write
something and be like this is the best i
can do it's it's good enough
and
as more and more time went on i started
to sort of
say to myself no i can actually do
better
and i think that that that is that comes
with experience
and i think that's part of just being
honest with yourself admitting that you
can do better
awesome i think okay so four so
caffeinated oh is that four i thought
that was five
oh sorry okay i must have missed one in
there okay um
man this is a good question sorry i'm
not just like rolling out with the uh
the answers uh
can i say travel i think travel is
important
um
meeting all sorts of different types of
people
uh that certainly inspires the
characters that i write
i guess routine and discipline was one
that i already said but i think it's
equally as important to be open to
breaking that routine to having this
sort of spontaneous fire inside of you
that makes you want to do something
you've never done before
i i
spent a lot of my
college years and post grad years you
know focusing on comedy and only now at
32 am i actually diving into horror and
i find that i'm actually
really enjoying it and it's not
something that i ever imagined wanting
to do
but i think being open to changing
you know your trajectory of things is is
a good thing
so spontaneity
and uh what is that eight
i believe so
seven or eight yeah
yeah i'm drawing a blank on the last two
i think having a good uh word processing
program certainly helps
i think uh i think
maybe that just contributes to the
structure of things but i feel
i feel a little bit more inspired if i
have just the proper equipment to write
that is a laptop personally i don't i
don't do like pen and paper or anything
like that and uh you know final draft or
celtx or something like that
um
that's a way more technical answer
and uh i think the last thing is
arguably the most important which would
just be the passion the desire to do it
i think you're gonna have a lot of
trouble if you are are
not enjoying some part of it i think
it's normal to
enter into periods where you are like i
hate this i want to move on to the next
thing already i think accepting that but
still reminding yourself of why you
started this to begin with is super
important and if you have that then you
can fall back on it and i think you will
be able to finish just about everything
that you start
excellent going back to number eight
about having the proper like writing
implements or whatever
have you ever tried to do a script or
write a script just using pages or word
and not using um
like a software program
uh i i have the i think the last time i
i get i guess i should say when i was
maybe when i was like 10 or 11 i would
actually write books and i would start
by grabbing a whole stack of paper and
folding them and then stapling it
and then i would draw pictures and i
would actually draw like write my story
in those books so i basically at the end
at age 11 had a
self-published single copy of my book um
and then
since then i
i've probably used you know word a
couple times and i've scribbled ideas in
in uh notebooks and i even like on my
phone right now i have a notepad of
ideas that i can scroll for days
but when i actually sit down to write a
screenplay now it's mainly just final
draft
excellent okay
great by the way do you have those books
still that you did
i gotta ask my parents i think we left
those in our basement in massachusetts
uh and i i'll ask if they cleaned it out
or if they kept them
i hope they kept them yeah
what's your process for coming up with
story concepts
my process for coming up with story
concepts
it ranges from
sitting down on a couch with victoria
with the intention of coming up with an
idea
or i could be driving
to pasadena or vegas you know or
assuming that the world is open
um and i am listening to music and all
of a sudden i just come up with an idea
that i'd like to explore
um so it really i it's
it's it's not always as simple as just
sitting down and thinking about an idea
more so it just kind of comes when i am
most relaxed do you think you come up
with story concepts more from memory
of things that happen in the past maybe
where you grew up or going to college or
does the present moment and observing
the world around you trigger story ideas
so i would say these story ideas come
from what is happening around me
currently
but when it comes time to actually
fleshing out a character and sort of
trying to write a dynamic relatable
realistic character i have no choice but
to go to my past and go to my memory and
sort of
summon up feelings or memories of people
that went through something similar or
some variation of whatever it is i'm
writing about
so it's it's definitely a combination of
those two
can you talk about your first couple of
weeks starting a screenplay where does
it start and what are those first two
weeks like it definitely starts with
that small nugget of excitement
wherever that may take place on the
couch with victoria or in my car driving
listening to music
and
i think the ideas that that really stick
that that i'm thinking about for a few
days
or even a few weeks
are the ones that i actually decide to
move forward with and begin writing
when i begin writing i will
make a cup of coffee sit down at my
computer
and just start writing and i don't
really
i don't really think too much about what
it is that i'm doing i try to just get
as much out as possible knowing that a
good portion of it will suck
and then
handing that to
someone like that i trust like victoria
or even my parents or friends and
getting some feedback now not all of
that happens in two weeks i would say
the first two weeks is mainly spent
questioning whether or not it's a good
idea thinking about
what why i would want to tell this story
thinking about why this would be
important or how i can make it important
on some level or make it personal to me
and once i decide that it is important
to me then i'll just sit down and and
start working it out on on paper
do you have people you give it to that
are harsh critics
i would say victoria is my harshest
critic
um
yeah my parents have been
pretty pretty supportive about
everything
so you know i take what they say with a
grain of salt
we have a couple of writer friends that
we like sending it to and they give
decent feedback
um
but yeah i definitely prefer to give it
to people that are going to say
you know i don't want to say meaner
things but just more truthful things
sure
it's like some people don't have a
filter and that's
can be helpful
sometimes and maybe sometimes it's not
so helpful but certainly certainly yeah
have you ever had an idea that you
thought was great
and you began writing it and you said
you know what this is just i'm not into
it i've lost interest and then you've
resumed like a year later and you loved
it absolutely there's there's actually
two ideas that i can think of um
one is a script i wrote a couple years
ago
fully with the intention of actually
making just with friends uh basically
just about a guy who doesn't really have
much life experience and so he sets out
to give himself life experience mainly a
traumatic experience
um and i i was really excited by that
idea but then i wrote it and it just
didn't really
uh it didn't really hit the way that i
wanted and so i i shelved it and a
couple years later i actually picked it
up again read through i was like there's
actually some really good pieces here
and i sort of just you know over like a
few days just uh
sort of started to edit from page one
another one is uh
it's called the philosophy circle and
it's it's a movie that i actually wrote
probably when i was like 23. and i've
that's the only script i can say that
i've actually edited consistently from
age 23 to as recently as maybe two years
ago so it's been sort of a work in
progress for about seven years or so
and why take so long with something
i think some stories are are more
complicated than others and i i think
sometimes if you get really excited
about something and you know that
there's something there but it didn't
really strike a chord with you
maybe it's best that you shelve it for a
little bit and then come back later i
think that can benefit a lot of projects
whereas some projects are way more
straightforward
and
regimented and you either kind of know
if you're on the right track or not
within
a much smaller period of time
i've heard some writers say i think it
was the writer of the goldfinch the
movie goldfinch that she loves um
the slow process of writing and she
doesn't want to rush it i think it took
her 12 years or so to finish that
so some people they really savor that
that
long process they don't want to
rush it
i i think that benefits some people and
some projects and i've found myself sort
of going both ways in that regard i've
spent a lot of time on certain projects
and then i've sort of i don't want to
say rushed through but definitely
cruised right through i think i the
first script i ever wrote was in a week
and i kind of followed the very
traditional three-act structure i knew
exactly where it was going i wouldn't
say it was it was uh you know
award-winning by the end but
um
some some stories also just come out of
you way easier than others some some
definitely take more time to marinate
and sort of figure out along the way
let's say you've written a screenplay
and you feel that it's a 9 out of 10.
it's almost there how would you get it
to be a 10
i don't think you ever can at least not
in your eyes i've never done anything
that i've said this is a 10 out of 10.
there's always things that i see room
for improvement
um is that a bad answer
no no that's good and i think some
people are hardwired that way like
nothing is ever they've got to always
tweak things and i think that makes
people great at whatever they do
i think you were talking about that
lately you have to be somewhat ocd i
think
um but yeah i mean i i don't even think
i've ever done anything that's nine out
of ten
i i think uh i think
it's this one giant journey to sort of
you know
make that 10 out of 10 project and i
think that's what gives me hope is this
constant evolution of wanting to be
better and wanting to make your next
project even more perfect than the last
one
but every time i make one i do look at
it and i say to myself that is
significantly better than the last one
at least more often than not
so i see growth and that's that's really
all i can ask for
i've never actually finished something
and been like 10 out of 10.
have you seen other people's work that
you're like
9 out of 10 10 out of 10.
i've seen other people's work that makes
me want to quit the film industry
because i don't think i'll ever live up
to it um
uh
i mean i remember seeing inception in
theaters and just
walking out of the theater and turning
to my friend and saying like i don't
even know if i want to like live in la
anymore and make movies because i'm
never going to make something like that
uh it it is just that that to me is just
such a wonderful brilliant movie
um
so
so yes i i martin mcdonough is another
of my favorites with like
screenwriting-wise i
just the dialogue that he writes i
i
aspire to write like that or or just you
know
think on that level um but there's
certainly a lot of people that i look up
to that i think i don't know if i can
ever
be that good
so does that make you then want to stop
or make you want to rise to their level
i know that sounds so cliche sorry i
mean i i say that sort of facetiously i
i will i'll never stop um
but
but yeah it was sort of like a funny
funny sarcastic joke you know and i said
that in the movie theater walking out of
inception
i'll never want to stop but it's uh
it's this
sort of abstract goal to sort of make
something that you watch
and elicit the same response in yourself
that you had when you watched something
like inception and i don't know if that
will ever happen i think i'm always
going to be my harshest critic
but
it's definitely something i aspire to do
and it's what keeps me going is just
that sort of nugget of hope
well a lot of times something that
inspires people is seeing bad work or
even in entrepreneurs they see some idea
and they go i could do better than that
and why does that person get to do that
i want to do it and there you go and
there's
there's the trajectory of their career
because it was all built on
seeing somebody else do something that
they think they failed at i think that i
think that's human to to look at someone
else's work and and say oh i'm i'm
better than that or or i can i can do
that why aren't i you know why haven't i
made it big yet i i sort of and i do
that on some level more so from a
business perspective because i want to
be able to make movies and you know have
have a career and actually support
myself doing that so i asked myself well
why are they getting paid all of this
money to do something i know i have the
skill set to do
um so i don't really i don't really
think in that way creatively as much
because
you know the story that you choose to
tell the movie that you make is
oftentimes a personal choice and and
who's to say one is better than the
other i think what you can judge is sort
of the
uh
you know the the technicals of it the
maybe the business of it you know why is
their movie picked up by lionsgate and
distributed worldwide when mine had all
the same shot on the same camera and you
know has just as much character growth
and
three-act structure format and all of
that
do you think it's good to have a little
bit of a a chip on the shoulder in terms
of having a competitor
or or does that not fuel you i think
some people it really fuels them i think
and others it doesn't i know i know
it fuels some people i know victoria has
said that it certainly helps to have
have that i don't want to say chip on
your shoulder but you know that kind of
a little bit of ego
you know like like as though it's a
competition i i
honestly i've never felt any kind of
competition i i very much felt like i've
sort of been on my own journey sort of
growing and like i said before i am my
harshest critic so something really
isn't good enough until i say
it's good enough and it certainly helps
you know going to film festivals and
having people pat you on the back and
say that was a wonderful movie like
great job and it gives me a little bit
more confidence but even if they said
that was a terrible movie i would
probably still
move along and
you know make another project regardless
um but it it certainly helps
is there such a thing as story intuition
i
would lean to saying yes i i think um
i think certain people do
have
something innate within them that uh
that
where they just understand character and
and they understand the direction that
stories need to go in
i think other people might require a
little bit more work to get there so i'm
not saying that some people just have it
and some people don't i just think some
people maybe have a little bit more
of an advantage based on where
they're from or where their mind was
focused at
on at a young age
um
that seems like a very scientific answer
to a metaphysical question
where do you think you fall on that
spectrum
i wouldn't say i have all the intuition
in the world
but i do i i've been interested in
storytelling and filmmaking since i was
11 or 12 so
i every the way that i've perceived the
world has sort of been you know with
that in mind i want to make a movie so i
think that certainly helps when you know
early on in your life that you want to
do something in entertainment because
you think in that way and so you know
your brain becomes wired in that way
and i think it helps when
fast forward 15 years you decide to
write a screenplay
you have now spent all this time
watching movies thinking i want to do
that and so it sort of it helps whereas
there are a lot of people that you know
might be a mechanical engineer and then
when they're
30 years old they're like actually i
want to become a screenwriter and then
it takes a little bit of learning and a
little bit of uh you know education
to to get there and they might be you
know even better than i was but
it requires more i guess
um
you know proactiveness it requires a
little bit more education to get
there right so on one end of the
spectrum maybe a story technician and on
the far end a story alchemist or
something yeah that's a good way of
putting it
in the middle is is sort of both okay
that sounds good
do you think that if intuitively someone
doesn't know a story that they'll never
be a writer you know you talked about
the engineer this hypothetical
writer i think i i actually believe that
anyone can be a writer i think i think
it's all just a matter of
how much you're willing to put into it
to actually tell an interesting story or
complete your story
i think everyone has a life experience
that can be interesting in some way
and i think it's just sort of up to them
to have the will to learn how to take
that experience and translate it into a
story that anyone can watch and anyone
can understand
and anyone can enjoy
and does the life experience have to be
necessarily traumatic definitely not no
it doesn't have to be traumatic it just
has to be it just has to be interesting
and memorable to you and and i think
some of those stories will resonate with
a lot of people some of those stories
will resonate with a small group of
people but i find it hard to believe
that there is
anyone in this world who has
only experienced one thing that no one
else has ever experienced before
and even if that is the case then that
would be a pretty damn interesting story
so writers can be happy productive
people
they don't have to be absolutely
self-loathing
no they definitely don't have to be no
i think it's normal to go through
periods of self-loathing and self-loving
um but yeah it's i don't think it's one
or the other
what do you think about learning
everything you can about structure and
then
forgetting it kind of going back to the
bruce lee uh quote right
i think i think it's a great idea to
take that approach i think
it's very important to have a foundation
an educational foundation on whatever
craft you're doing because there are
plenty of people that came before you
that
knew what they were doing and they did
it exceptionally well
and so you want to learn from those
people and once you learn sort of how to
you know put together a story or put
together a movie this really can be
uh you know
this can be attributed to any craft in
the world
then you can then infuse your own
experience onto that and create
something new and original how do you
develop character
by looking at my own experience or
talking to other people that have had an
experience similar to whatever character
it is that i'm writing
i
like to think i have some level of
intuition with how people behave but i'm
always surprised and especially when
writing a female character for example
i'm not the best
source of information because i'm not a
female so i will ask
girls i'll go to victoria and ask like
help me help me craft this character
because everybody thinks in a in a
different way
and
it's it's definitely important to have
that sort of well-rounded um
point of view and it's it's important to
sort of have
i think multiple voices be just as there
would be multiple
uh characters in your story it's
important to have multiple voices at
least giving you the writer
feedback giving you the writer some
direction to go in or some understanding
of these characters
what would you say is the most perfect
fictional character whether be in a
novel or
film one of my f this is a strange
answer to that one of my favorite
characters in film and one of my
favorite movies is um a serious man coen
brothers
and uh the main uh the main character in
that
is basically
going about his everyday life just
trying his hardest trying his best
trying to be a good person
and there's there's always something
around him that's happening that's sort
of throwing a wrench into his plan
and
it's not like he did anything wrong he's
just an ordinary guy with a family
and um one thing after another happens
and a storm is literally coming
throughout the entire duration of the
movie
and i thought that that was just such a
beautiful representation of life
and when i watched that movie
and every time i've watched it
thereafter i've watched it multiple
times and find new little you know gems
within it
uh i it's just really resonated with me
i've i've looked at that movie and
watched that character a million times
and thought yes i can relate to that
i love that movie as well i love the
character of psy yeah and not so much
because psy i mean sai is actually a
horrible person but you don't know
spoiler alert but you don't know that at
first and so
the fact that he seems a little more
genuine
and then the the needle moves and you
see wow this person's actually like a
saboteur
and
i don't know such as life you know you
don't always
you don't always know sometimes exactly
yeah but that's that's a great film as
well and it's a it's a great um
character study and i also like the
brother in the film
i thought the brother was a good because
his life is probably more damaged than
you know michael stalwark's character
exactly it's uh richard kind right
oh is that right okay sorry yeah i don't
know that's the uh that's the actor's
name i think yeah okay
why did you switch from comedy
filmmaking to horror well i i wouldn't
say that i i switched as much as i'm
just sort of trying something new at
this time um i
you know like like i said before i
definitely needed a career and ever
since i was in high school i've always
known that horror is a great way to
break in
but my instincts were sort of more
pushed towards comedy and so i spent a
lot of time doing that and i think i did
it decently well
uh but now you know in in sort of an
effort to to experiment and also you
know launch a career i think it was a
great
it was a great
it was just a great uh what what word am
i looking for
uh idea to just sort of try a different
genre because i could sort of flex my
filmmaking muscle which which i wasn't
really doing in comedy as much but with
horror i think there's a lot more
room to sort of explore and be creative
and inventive and work with lighting and
camera angles
um and then
just from a
career perspective
when we release these i mean these get a
lot
more attention than if i were to you
know release a comedy sketch or a even a
romantic comedy movie
people people really love horror
you think too because horror can be more
not just regional but other people in
other countries can pick up more on
scares rather than
a little nuance here and there
absolutely funny thing that's that's a
huge part of it i think i think you know
someone in japan who doesn't speak any
english uh can still see a scary monster
and have a feeling
uh whereas they might not watch you know
king of staten island and understand the
nuances of every
joke
sure sure and there's east coast humor
versus west coast too so that's your
true the east coast yeah that's true
there's definitely there's definitely
differences there
what if you learned about making people
laugh i've always liked making people
laugh because it's um
it's uh
it's a
visceral response that
sort of gives you as a creator some
sometimes the validation that you need
that you're
putting out some good content or good
material
um it
seeing i mean seeing a smile on
someone's face makes me smile so it's
there there's no harm there
um there's there's a lot of good stuff
about making people laugh
do you think sarcasm is is a dirty word
no i'm incredibly sarcastic and i don't
i don't mean that sarcastically i'm dead
serious
what have you learned about writing
something scary
i think
i've heard a lot of people say this i do
find a lot of similarities between
horror and comedy you kind of have a
build up and then a punch line
um you know or a set up in a punch line
or a
a slow build and then a scare
so they're very similar and so if
there's one thing i've learned about
horror is that it's actually very
similar to comedy
um and you kind of get that same
visceral reaction from your audience
seeing them jump as you would in comedy
seeing them laugh
and it and it feels good to see that
it's it's super cool
and and we we've been releasing these
horror shorts on our on our youtube
channel
and i've seen
so many people make reaction videos to
watching our horror shorts and that is a
very rewarding and interesting thing to
see literally just looking into
someone's eyes watching them as they
watch your movie i've never ever
experienced that in anything else i've
ever made before
but it's it's super cool which horror
protagonist do you most identify with
that's a tough question i um
it seems like a lot of protagonists in
horror movies have experienced or gone
through some really traumatic life
experience
so
i'm sure i identify you know on some
level obviously they're they're complete
they're exaggerated tenfold in movies
um i just saw doctors sleep
and i loved that one uh ewan mcgregor's
character was fantastic
um i'd have to think about that one a
little bit more it's it's hard to
imagine a
a protagonist in a horror film that that
i've really resonated with before maybe
um
the babadook
the the lead and the babadook that was a
really interesting movie because i think
everyone has some demon inside of them
in some way or another
and i think that's what made that movie
so great is it was just a visual
representation of something we all
we all experience on some level maybe
not you know grief to that extent some
people probably have definitely have
experienced grief to that extent um a
lot of people even if they haven't
can still understand this sort of
demon inside that you know is
wants to get out and and it's it's that
movie was just such an interesting
exploration of that
and sort of how you
either censor yourself or you know push
certain things away and yeah it was a
great movie
can you talk more about your process for
writing comedy comedy it's it's it's
very very hard to write um
and i i wouldn't say i have any
particular process i think when writing
a screenplay
it's really important and and this is
definitely true for just about any genre
but i think in comedy in particular it's
very important that the
concept itself
starts off from a in a funny interesting
place
and i think it i think for me
uh i know victoria hates this word uh
but but when something is grounded even
if it's sort of uh
an a crazy abstract supernatural you
know movie or concept so long as the
characters and the reactions stay
grounded i think that's very important
to comedy
um
so
you want to start with a
concept that is inherently funny
and then you sort of build characters
off of that that support the concept and
are
completely different
and i i definitely enjoy writing the
dialogue i think more so than anything
else
because just
writing odd
weird quirky fast-paced
funny jokes is rewarding and if it it's
fun to write because i sometimes find
myself laughing while coming up with
ideas whereas if i'm if i'm writing a
you know a drama or a horror movie
i it's not always as fun sometimes it's
just you know
scary or you kind of have to go
dig a little deeper to actually find
something worth writing about comedy it
just if it makes you laugh i think it it
works
so it's definitely more fun
did you watch a lot of seinfeld when you
were a kid absolutely
and curb your enthusiasm curb your
enthusiasm got me through
high school and college
and it still does today and a lot of
people even say i'm a lot like larry
david
do comedy and horror have the same story
beats
i think they're very similar for sure
like i said you know before i do think
that har will sort of have a slow build
and then a jump scare
whereas comedy will have a
setup and a punch line
uh when it comes to the actual you know
overall structure of of a full-length
screenplay i
i think just about every genre
should follow generally the same kind of
rules
loose rules can be broken
but
in that regard i don't think there's any
difference
did you ever try your hand at stand-up
comedy aaron my mom did um i haven't
um i've actually i do have a word
document with some like stand-up jokes
or i have it in my phone somewhere
um but i've never tried stand-up i don't
i don't know if that's something i want
to do
how cool so would your mom perform at
comedy clubs um i think she's tried it
just a couple times yeah i think the
first time she did it she was in her 50s
wow yeah
and so
do you remember like i guess you're
probably too young to go to the club or
can you tell me about that that's
fascinating uh well i actually i wasn't
there
i was i was out here in l.a um but she
just there was this it was like a cafe
in massachusetts and they had an open
mic night
and uh she went and tried it out
and uh i was thinking uh good for you
that's that's awesome i don't i don't
know if i would have the confidence to
do that i do think stand-up comedy is
one of the most difficult uh
performances any any human can can do
i think it's it's nerve-wracking it's uh
difficult and
if i were to do stand-up i'd want to be
i'd want to be everything
intellectually stimulating hilarious
low brow and highbrow all at the same
time
and um
it it would require just as much work if
not more as writing a screenplay which
is something i'd prefer to spend my time
doing anyway
so just with story beats there's
probably timing and things like that
with stand up as as well oh absolutely i
think some of the best stand-up
comedians actually have a full
structured story well they'll start with
something and sort of have the story
that weaves in and out all the way
through up until the end which is just
one giant callback joke to everything
that came before it
and i have a lot of respect for that and
i love stand up every time i see a new
stand-up special released on netflix i
get very excited
yeah and and not just the concept of
hecklers but also people in the audience
like if you watch old robin williams
footage
people aren't even like challenging him
and he's just
you know pointing them out and so he has
new material to work off of even if his
set is
or was
um
one thing he's got new things to kind of
work off and pull absolutely i mean
robin williams is he's genius i think
i've seen some of those some of those
videos that you're talking about um i
mean yeah he's he's super quick and
you definitely need a thick skin to to
do that
and you just need to really be able to
think on your feet which i can't which
you know or at least not as well as
evidenced by this interview you know i'm
not coming up with the answers right
away um i i definitely am the type of
person that i need time to like think
about things and give a good answer i
don't want to just come out with it you
know
and so
i don't know how i'd respond to hecklers
i wouldn't necessarily have a quip you
know just
that that uh quick
so again going back to the uh the
competitor or the the chip on the
shoulder
you'd rather be the um
you know the michael jordan documentary
he
showed that he needed that you know
right right
push him and make him great so you're
more the one that's the internal
again going back to the two schools yeah
for better or worse i don't know which
which outlook is better um
but um
yeah i i i at least try not to have a
chip on my shoulder
some chips work some chips definitely do
i mean that you need you need a certain
level of confidence in yourself to just
push through
um
but
yeah i think i think it's like i said
before i'm sort of uh i'm sort of a
paradox i think a lot of people are a
paradox you need
your days where you're like i'm king of
the world i can do anything and then you
need the days just as much where
you question everything your reality who
am i and why am i doing this with my
life i think that balance is important
and i think it's dangerous to tip
anything in any one extreme direction
but
you know it's a giant pendulum that you
just need to constantly balance
so your mom only did two stand up
um i love that segue
uh okay yeah she uh i think she tried it
i think she tried it twice
and um yeah she said she got a few
laughs at my father's expense
but i i think i think it went pretty
well for her first time
what have you learned about writing
villains
writing villains i think
writing villains should be approached
the same way that writing any other
character or protagonist should be
approached i
a good villain is
you understand why they're doing what
they're doing and you understand uh
what they want just as much as you
understand what the protagonist wants
that's who's one of your favorite
villains
one that actually comes to mind is uh
javier bardem and no country for old men
uh there's something terrifying about
him
but in the end
he just kind of
dies
naturally without any
you know with kind of indirectly of the
events of the movie that took place
see it kind of which is what also what i
love about that movie is you have this
these tropes that that the characters
and the story follows
and then it's just completely broken by
the end
and you're sort of left with an even
more terrifying feeling or a more
freeing feeling depending on how you
want to look at it that there really is
no
distinct good or bad in the world and if
there is there is no real justice or
maybe there is it's so it's all a
paradox it's all a matter of how you
look at it
so that's i think that that was he was a
great character and that was a great
movie what about what's one of your most
hated villains
i feel like if i actually watched a
movie and genuinely
hated a character i might i might not
like the movie that much a part of me
wants to kind of like on some level
everybody that i watch even if they're
uh
the antagonist you kind of want to like
who they are and what they're about or
at least get something out of it
um someone that is just pure evil i find
to be unrealistic
um
so now i'm trying to think of movies
with sort of just purely evil characters
uh you know
and uh i guess i would need i would
still need some more time time with that
man i don't i don't know
what about the joker i do i do think
that the joker they they definitely did
a good job of
and i'm talking about like the most
recent joker they definitely did a good
job of sort of showing you know this guy
who is disturbed i i personally had
trouble
relating
to to uh that character at least in the
latest version um mainly just because it
was a movie about this you know mentally
ill person
and and it's it's it can be fascinating
to watch at certain points but
he wasn't really as much of a villain in
that movie
um
i you know maybe in like the classic
batman uh
uh comics you know he the joker is
certainly portrayed more so as a villain
and in that case it is more black and
white but the the origin of him i guess
is
is definitely more of a
character study on someone with mental
illness and therefore i wouldn't even
look at it look at him as a villain at
all
i don't know if that's a pretentious
answer but uh yeah no
no there's been a lot of debate i know
about that character and yeah
yeah i mean that was an interesting
movie and and i i wouldn't say it was my
favorite movie um i didn't hate it i
didn't love it i it was definitely a
different approach
um but
yeah i look at the dark knight and i
find you know i find uh heath ledger in
that movie
just to be
very well rounded and a wonderful
wonderfully written villain because
he is actually
he's giving reason for why what he for
what he does
and
the the sort of you know
um
again what's the what's the word i'm
looking for the the predicaments that he
puts the protagonist in are very
difficult situations that it's like what
do you do in this situation it's it's a
and i think that's that's a great you
know predicament to put your protagonist
in
is something that anyone can watch and
be like i don't know what i would do in
that situation i want to see how this
person is going to do it
so you love christopher nolan i do yeah
yeah
i believe you made your first feature
film in 2013 did you think upon making
that your life was going to change i
guess if i were to ever have a period of
my life where i did have a chip on my
shoulder it was in 2012 making that
movie um
i i
i didn't really i didn't know what was
gonna happen with it i i was very much
focused on just making a movie that i
wanted to make and had zero
intention of trying to make something
marketable or or anything all i wanted
out of it was
sort of just you know i just wanted to
open a door and have
maybe an agent that can help me make my
next movie
or
garner the attention of some investors
that would finance the next movie
uh while making it it was an absolute
blast uh and i definitely hope for the
best i didn't if you were to actually
ask me truthfully if i thought this was
gonna be my big break i'd probably say
no i don't think so
but i just sort of wanted to prove to
myself that i could make a coherent
story
and and i think i successfully did that
at least you know when i was 20 23 years
old or so
do you really think that's a chip on
your shoulder or more just creative
longing just wanting to make something
it was probably probably more creative
longing i mean i it wasn't like in a
cocky way i of course hoped that we
would
get in a sundance and make a million
dollars and there was a small part of my
mind that thought
that could happen i could see that
happening
now i don't really think in that way so
so when i was younger i definitely
you know the whole sundance dream and
selling your movie for for millions and
millions of dollars was
it was much more of a possibility in my
mind back then whereas now
it might happen but i don't even i don't
even think about that now now i focus so
much more on
the actual content i'm trying to make
and just making the best possible movie
i can
would you advise other first-time
filmmakers not just a short but a
feature
that it'd be really more of a
again cliche term but a passion project
rather than aiming for this
incredible distribution deal
that's that's a very difficult question
to answer and i know i'm sure a lot of
people will watch this and and i want to
i want to be careful with my word choice
because i don't want to like lead anyone
down the wrong path um
you know obviously everyone's different
and personally i think it's important to
think
you know about the business of it and
also think creatively
just how everything else seems to be a
balance in life you also need the
balance of business and creative like
you at least if if you want to make a
living doing this and only this
personally i think that's really
important
um
there are plenty of people who i who i
you know look up to that
not once have ever thought about the
business part of things in fact they
despise it and they've only focused on
the creative part of it and
and that's worked out well for them and
then there's plenty of people that only
focus on the business and you watch
their movie and you can tell but the
business is really working out and the
the creativity part of it kind of
suffers for me i like to keep both in
mind
all the time
when i'm actually on set or when i'm
actually in front of my computer writing
i first and foremost
i do my best to compartmentalize and i i
just focus on the story and what it is
that i'm actually writing about what it
is i want to say and then when we go
through the revision stage it's like all
right well this might be more relatable
or we might be able to actually
call this a horror film if we add a few
more you know jump scares or you know
just sort of add to it fluff it up to
sort of take your original creative
vision and make it a little bit more
marketable so you can make money and do
it again
uh what mistakes did you make with 15
north
that have always stuck with you that
then going forward with the new project
you always remember those mistakes and
try to correct anything whether it's in
pre-production post
i think i spent too much on
post-production
i think i i think i i realized later on
that i could actually do a lot more
myself at least in in that small of a
budget i could do a lot more
uh instead of you know spending money
and
hiring you know someone else to do
certain things
um although then again the entire
landscape has changed and you're able to
do so much more from home now than you
were just seven years ago
i'm trying to think of of the biggest
mistake
i would say the biggest mistake that i
made on my first movie
was
not spending enough time on the script
i definitely approached the entire
project
with this attitude of i just want to
make a movie i want to make it real i'm
just going to keep the cameras rolling
and
you know get natural performances it's
very sort of mumble core style and i
think that that is good but i didn't
prepare enough i feel like i could have
fleshed out the story a lot more with
you know just
really focus on a more traditional
three-act structure and and focus on
writing characters with more depth and
and that sort of thing
if there was one thing i could do over
again that would probably be it is just
spend more time focusing on the actual
script
do you think that prompted your youtube
channel because you give such helpful
tips with your channel do you think that
prompted
you to want to start it or no
certainly i mean i i think
the the content i'm putting out on on my
youtube channels is basically just
everything i wanted to see you know when
i was when i was a few years younger i
wanted to see people creating content
from home by themselves and
i enjoy that i love seeing people and
what they're able to do
without big studios behind them uh would
i take a studio job of course
but i i really get a kick out of this
just home brewed you know do-it-yourself
kind of
approach
i think your top video um is about the
using um
the drawing aspect in adobe oh yeah
the the scribble animation
that's funny did you know that would be
so popular uh no not not really i mean i
know it's a it's a popular effect um
but
yeah with that kind of thing you never
really know it's gonna be popular with
our other channel you know social house
films that's a lot more
cut and dry you know if you if you make
a short horror film and it looks pretty
and the monster looks scary then it's
probably going to do pretty well
uh these tutorials it's it's hard to
sort of be on the pulse of what
effect is going to be
you know the most desirable
now that now that tick tock is a thing
you know a lot of people are trying to
like create their own effects at home
and and so
i i never know what that next thing is
going to be
i have a quote here aaron and it reads i
selfishly like a lot of first-time
directors because they over prepare
they are super eager and they have very
little ego
and that quote is from none other than
mark duplass of the duploss brothers
i definitely agree with that um
yeah i think uh i i do think that when
you're a new director you feel like you
have something to prove and i think it
was david f sandberg who said that you
want to
prepare 200 just to get 100
results
and i think especially first-time
directors because they have something
to prove or
uh they're nervous
they tend to over prepare a little bit
and when it comes to filmmaking that's
definitely not a bad thing
i i've noticed that my
movies get significantly better if i
actually plan
every single shot every single moment
it sounds grueling and tedious and
difficult and it absolutely is
but
it also it also sounds obvious of course
you prepare you do a better job but
it makes a world of a difference i
remember earlier on in my in my you know
career i remember you you actually asked
if uh
what was one of the biggest mistakes i
learned with my first feature
and i would say
not
preparing every single shot
i think especially on a much smaller
budget film
if you actually
over prepare you know exactly what
you're going to shoot and you're going
to know every single moment that it is
that you're shooting
uh then the the finished product is
gonna be so much better
did you storyboard do anything like that
i did not storyboard 15 north it was it
was very much again from this approach
of i just want to get two cameras
rolling at the same time sort of shoot
it in this very mumble corey documentary
style
didn't want to really do that much
planning i did have a loose shot list
just to sort of make sure i covered you
know basically got all the coverage that
i needed
but
since that movie i've definitely spent a
lot more time focusing on what's
actually in the frame
on that movie it was just sort of like
let's point a camera at this actor get
their lines and let's just do a couple
takes of that and move on
i don't really do that anymore
how does a writer or filmmaker earn
their audience
that's that's also a good question i i
think
a writer filmmaker probably earns their
audience
by
being honest with themselves i think
it's like making a friend you know if
you are
if you're a good person and you have
good intentions and you
care about what it is that you're saying
i think people are going to
listen and they're going to be
interested
if you if you seem like you're you know
making a movie or telling a story for
all the wrong reasons i think that's
gonna
it's gonna shine through in your work
uh so i think you know you you
definitely earn an audience's trust in
that way and then of course you know the
the technical aspect of it if it looks
terrible
uh
it's going to be distracting and nobody
nobody's going to really
even take the time to watch it even if
the content itself is riveting and good
uh you know you kind of you sort of need
this baseline production value to say
okay
i know what i'm doing now hear what i
have to say
and what if you build an audience and
they become so invested in your stories
and your characters that they revolt
because they
wanted those characters and stories to
become something else but you as the
creator it's your imagination
but how much does the audience
say involved in some of that
how much say do they have if i could
start a revolution i'd i i'd be happy i
could i could die early um
i i guess the best example i i mean i've
never really made anything overly
controversial
uh that would cause anyone to revolt
about anything however there is one
horror short that we just released a few
weeks ago called diet
and we wanted to play with the tropes of
sort of what makes a traditional horror
film where you just have this you know
usually it's a girl just home alone
and something scary happens
she hears a noise or something is at the
window and she goes up to it
and it's nothing and then she goes into
bed and then turns around there's a
scary monster and that's it that's the
end it's it's like the most cliche kind
of like little horror short you can
imagine and so i was thinking of a way
to play around with that
and have all of those same tropes but
then at the very end you just have that
main character die of natural causes in
which case he just dies of uh choking on
a carrot
and then a monster in the closet reveals
herself
and sighs with disappointment because
she couldn't fulfill her duty
as a scary monster who terrorizes her
victims uh so we released that and you
know i thought it was like kind of a
funny comedy horror idea a lot of people
were confused by it a lot of people got
it a lot of people were like what the
hell did i just watch that that doesn't
make any sense
um so that was actually very interesting
and it was particularly interesting to
watch reaction videos of that film
erin are you saying that every horror
short that you do people do reaction
videos too just about every horror short
act actually i think every horror short
that we've made there are reaction
videos online
and and i i do love watching them some
we even have shared a couple to our
social house films facebook page
do they usually let you know or do you
find them in search
there's only been one person that's ever
let us know um everyone else just they
just do it on their own but i mean
that's that's fair i they they don't
need to let us know if they want to
watch it and react to it then so be it
you know that's why it's there
how does that feel that people are that
affected by your work that they're
taking time to make a reaction video i
think it's super cool it's the it's the
it's just such a cool feeling and
experience to watch someone else watch
what you just made
and
literally look them in the eye
every moment of you know the film that
you that you just put out there
and sometimes you see genuine terror on
their face and it's it's just such a
rewarding thing to see that kind of
visceral response from a complete
stranger
have you ever reached out to a creator
and given feedback good or bad
i tried to get an internship at apatow
productions when i first
moved out here
um
actually i made a short
horror film come to think of it it was a
short hard documentary
it was like a mockumentary about the
making of a zombie movie about love
and
one of the guys that i made it with
was family friends with larry david and
gave him a copy and i think i was like i
don't know i was maybe 17 or 18 at this
time
and larry david watched it
and
told my friend hey tell you know jesse
and aaron the other filmmakers that they
did a great job
and that was uh that was super cool
so i i remember kind of pushing my
friend like hey you should you know
larry david you should uh give this to
him not necessarily his genre but i'd be
curious to you know i'm a huge fan of
larry david so
i'd love to see you know what he thinks
how do you work with actors
i actually read a book on this it's
called i'll be in my trailer
uh i forget who wrote it very well known
director
uh and there was a lot a lot of very
interesting
sort of you know
experiences that this director had and
i think i subconsciously remembered a
lot of that book too which is
you know you kind of you want to create
an environment that is comfortable you
know much like you guys are doing right
now it helps me if i feel comfortable
when i'm
talking or performing or whatever
so you know you want to you want to keep
things
comfortable does to me it doesn't really
matter what the feel of the scene is
everyone should always be
as comfortable as you can make them all
the time i think
and once you've sort of created that
environment then you want them to know
that they're open to experimentation
that they're open to sort of try things
you know that
they might otherwise be scared to do if
they feel like this is a visionary
director and they know you know that
director knows exactly what he or she
wants to do then you know i i think it's
important to
give that actor the freedom to
experiment try new things because
i don't always know best and sometimes
actors have done something that i've
i could not have imagined of
and that's super cool to watch
whereas if we go back to stand-up comedy
even though people have the freedom to
be spontaneous in the room
that
feeling isn't always going to be there
you think you think one brings out a
better performance in people
i think i think i mean i definitely
think stand-up comedy is uh is
definitely it's it's a form of acting
for sure
um
it's
i i also think stand-up comedy is
probably one of the most uncomfortable
positions you can put yourself in
but i think
i i think good stand-ups
it's sort of on them because there is no
director it's a completely different
medium it's on them to
you know make themselves feel
comfortable on stage and and feel give
themselves the freedom to you know do
what they want
if that makes sense
sure
sure you're right yeah because each one
kind of has its own role
there's some very self-deprecating
comics there's some that they turn it on
the audience
yeah so
that's very true it is it is their
character
do you still make money or residuals off
your first feature film i think i made a
total of about 25
now off of 15 north
um
i guess that was a good learning
experience uh the biggest mistake with
15 north actually come to think of it
came to distribution
um not with the actual creation of the
movie but with the getting it out there
into the world
we went through like a third party sort
of tertiary company that approached us
after our premiere
and
they said that they wanted to distribute
the movie they loved it we were you know
young early 20s we were super excited to
even have a distribution company
approach us
um so we signed the contract didn't get
a lawyer
um basically just you know signed it
away and this was a you know like i said
it was a third party company that
basically just went through an
aggregator
uh and we never saw a dime back we never
saw anything
and so what i learned from that movie
was
really
know what you're doing when it comes to
distribution and get a lawyer if you can
and do your research and
be open to a negotiation you're allowed
to this is a business and you are
allowed to negotiate
uh ownership for your film
do you still own the rights to it
so about two years ago i had the
contract terminated that tertiary
company actually went out of business
and or was bought by another company and
so we terminated the contract and now
i self-distributed it on amazon amazon
prime
yeah which is why i say i made about 25
bucks because i think i get six cents
for every hour watched or something like
that
yeah
so how long was it sort of out of your
hands you said it was 2012 when you
started filming it was 2012 uh when we
shot it i think it came out in 2013
and then
the contract i think ran for six years
or seven years and i terminated it maybe
just a couple months before the contract
was expired anyway
your second feature film electric love
is on hulu currently yes it is
and so how did that happen how did you
how did you get that hulu deal well i
took everything i learned from my first
movie 15 north and and when especially
when it came to distribution and we
applied it to electric love we had
we had a friend who uh knew someone at
gravitas ventures
and um
he was able to connect us with the with
the people over there and they
were interested in the film uh we even
were offered a an mg minimum guarantee
or like an advance
which was for like about a tenth of our
budget which
was super exciting because i had never
i'd never experienced anything like that
and distribution for independent film is
such a mystery to me
uh
so we
we actually did not jump right away we
were sort of determining whether or not
we wanted to
go with that or
uh perhaps you know field inquiries from
sales agents or other distribution
companies but anyway we ended up going
with gravitas and
they
had it distributed internationally and
then they sold it to hulu
and that was it was very exciting and we
actually made about half of our budget
back just from that
so it was a very validating and exciting
and just super cool thing
to happen
and what types of things do you need to
do to get the film ready to show on a
platform like hulu actually i'm trying
to think of we actually just got an
email today with a list of things that
apparently they're still missing
so you need to deliver the film in its
you know 4k
uh format you need to
put together an m e track which is a
music and effects track which is
basically without the dialogue
that way internationally they can dub
over it in any language
you need a complete transcription of
every line spoken in the entire movie
uh there's there's a lot of deliverables
that are required and every platform
sort of requires something different
um but the distributor sort of tells you
hey we need this or hey we need this and
then we just you know rushed to do it
and if i can do it myself then i will um
i think there were a couple things that
we needed to hire out
like the the m e track
um but but
you know the distributor tells you what
they need and so you give it to them how
long has it been on hulu i think it's
been on hulu now for
i want to say a year
i
it actually no
maybe six months victoria would know i
forget
i forget
has anyone reached out to you about the
film
i loved it watched it this reminds me of
me
i've got i've gotten a couple like
friend request friend requests on
facebook um or you know dms and uh on
instagram and uh
but you know not nothing crazy i think
more so the the actors have received
some feedback i've heard
uh zach one of the stars of the movie
say he's has people from around the
world message him
um yeah
i did post
a copy or a photo of me holding up the
blu-ray
when it came out on reddit
and i i posted that to the filmmakers
subreddit and i think i got like a
thousand up votes or something a lot of
other filmmakers were asking you know
questions about it and i do definitely
try to
make myself available to people
independent filmmakers that have
questions about distribution i think
it's such a secret for some reason and
nobody likes discussing numbers
and um
i think that only works to the advantage
of the distributor and i think it's
important for filmmakers like us to
actually share this information and
learn how to properly distribute your
movie and
make money on it if you can
what have you found is the best way to
make money as a filmmaker to shoot
weddings probably
no i mean it it depends what what level
you're at and in high school that that
is what i did i shot weddings at bar
mitzvahs
um
nowadays i probably make the most
getting hired by companies to just shoot
music videos
um we we actually just started
monetizing our youtube channel so that's
that's a
nice you know extra source of income
um
and
surprisingly making
independent films that fit within a
certain budget
now just with the
with all of these streaming platforms
it's actually a lot easier to make your
money back and then some on independent
movies so electric love was about a
hundred thousand dollars and so far i
think we've made about 70 000 of that
back
and it's a seven year
uh term that you sign with the
distributor that we signed
and so over seven years we certainly
plan on breaking even hopefully and then
even making a little bit after that it
doesn't happen immediately
so you definitely have to give it some
time before you even see you know your
first check in the mail i think it was
about two years before we received our
first check from electric love after its
release
but
as assuming you do it correctly then you
can certainly make money back doing that
and it's what i really respect about the
duploss brothers they
figured out their business model and it
works for them and and i
i've always had a lot of respect for
them they create their own material they
have their pipeline they put it through
they produce other other people's movies
and
it's profitable and they're able to do
it again and again and again
what is that budget range that you think
is the profitable budget range i would
say
it's hard it's hard to give like exact
numbers if i had to break it down i'd
probably say try to keep it
below a hundred thousand dollars
um especially if it's
not a horror movie
i think if you make a horror film
there's there's going to be a lot more
uh distributors nowadays that are
willing to distribute something like
that because like we were talking about
before
it can be distributed to just about any
country non-english speaking country and
still translate people will still enjoy
it
whereas a romantic comedy about online
dating in los angeles won't necessarily
translate to you know someone in japan
or
some country that doesn't speak english
as much um
so yeah
and you said your budget for electric
love was around a hundred thousand
it was it was about a hundred thousand
dollars and then hulu we got it we got
50k from hulu which was half the budget
and um again i i i like sharing the
numbers mainly just to to help
filmmakers sort of get an idea as to
what they can do uh with these
these
with films in this sort of budget range
because sorry do you mind if i ask how
you raised that budget
sure so a lot of it was uh self-financed
um i i put up a little basically just
savings from like the past since 15
north for the past five six years and
it's not something i would recommend
everyone do
um i did it and it's slowly working out
but i was able to you know finance a lot
myself and another huge part of it and
this is like the second half is
victoria actually was able to lock a lot
of brand collaborations so she comes
from a background of instagram and you
know doing sponsorships and brand
collabs and we were able to get a lot of
our wardrobe paid for free meals uh even
you know money given to us
we had friends come in and just kick in
a little bit
so it was very much sort of like a
crowdsourced kind of kind of thing
and honestly if i didn't have
savings you know five years worth of
savings to put into it
i still would have made it we just would
have done things a little bit
differently
so it's definitely possible
and with these brand collaborations is
there a site you would go to to find
brands or you were just cold calling
what might fit with the movie
or emailing we were pretty much just
cold emailing companies uh you know that
had products or services that we could
somehow
include in the film without it being too
obvious
i see so you're finding things that
would fit
with the film and making a list and then
reaching out and finding who their brand
sort of manager is exactly and and
victoria is is so good at that she
really just excels in in that in
marketing and producing and everything
in that department
was your pitch a long pitch or was it
more to the point to these brands um
it's pretty to the point
i think at a certain point too even when
it came to post we even had like a
little
loose trailer cut together that we could
send over and say here hey here's what
the movie looks like and here's what it
is and we even got some brand deals
after the fact when it came time to
putting together a premiere
um
so
yeah you know just be direct don't you
know be honest about what you're doing
um
tell them where where the movie might go
and uh you know who's in it
that kind of stuff matters in that
regard
and uh hope for the best i think if you
send out you know 200 emails two
companies might respond with a yes
with the brand email would you talk up
sort of like what you could do for them
more so than hey this is who we are you
know i see a lot of pitches and
sometimes it's more about this is who i
am and this is and that's great and i
understand people are proud of their
work but sometimes it falls short in
what they can do
for the person they're asking something
from
i i actually would love to bring up uh
one of victoria's emails so i could just
read exactly how she uh you know wrote
it
but i i think she
would sort of
focus on how this is going to benefit
their company
while simultaneously saying
you know
and and not in these exact words but we
know what we're doing and this movie is
going to have eyeballs on it
so it's kind of like uh you know we're
professionals and this can benefit you
right
and just last question about it would
you try would you email them a second
time if you heard no or or did i'm sorry
if you didn't hear anything um
traditionally not
uh i mean
i i i think we just emailed so many
companies at a certain point that it was
even hard to keep track of um
again i don't know if that is like the
best method but i see no harm in it and
you know if a no is a no it doesn't it
doesn't bother us um you know we've had
plenty of rejection working in
entertainment anyway so uh you know if a
company is like not for us no big deal
and if they don't answer then you know
there's there's plenty of other uh
brands that we could reach out to
where was the premiere
at the uh was it the i think it was the
aria fine arts theater on wilshire
nice yeah
what do you know about filmmaking that
you wish you knew before and again i
realized that's you know that's like a
typical job interview question but
there's a lot of weight to it and sure i
mean i i think the really the biggest
thing that i
have learned
is just the secrets of distribution the
actual filmmaking part
you you just you just need to make
mistakes in order to grow so
you know with the actual creativity and
putting it together and
not planning and seeing how that turns
out and then doing a little more
planning and seeing how that turns out
it's all it really is all part of the
process and it's it's something that
everyone i think needs to go through
even if they try not to they're going to
make mistakes it's necessary
uh to make the best movie the only like
cold hard facts that you can actually
learn is pretty much now that i made the
movie how do i get it out there and
that's also always evolving and changing
so you know the
the means of distribution seven years
ago is completely different than what it
is now uh so you have to stay on top of
that but
sort of just understanding
what your film's value is and
what is possible is the the biggest
thing that i've learned over the past
few years
how do you know what the value is
i guess what i mean by value is sort of
having the confidence
to to know that there is an audience for
your film if you if you you know put in
this
some if you put in a year's worth of
time and effort into making a movie
uh there is going to be an audience for
it somewhere you know there's there's a
lot of people in this world and and
a lot of people have tvs and computers
and
nowadays that's all you need to share
content and even if you can't get
distribution
you can self-distribute now like i i
wasn't able to do that
10 years ago and if i did then i just
didn't know about it
now it's so much more user friendly and
you can get your movie on amazon prime
like that with with their amazon video
direct service
um
so it really it's it's inspiring
and it gives me hope knowing that the
success of your film relies entirely on
the work that you put into it
can you share with us the process of
getting your movie on amazon prime yeah
so it's a service called amazon a video
direct and i i did i set this up about a
year and a half ago for our first movie
and you really just follow the
instructions you upload your file
you upload your subtitles
and after it's approved
you literally just link it to your you
know bank account and you have all the
analytics and everything and it's on you
to market and promote your movie and you
can choose whether or not you want to
put it on prime so prime users can
stream it for free or you can set it you
know to just for rental and purchase um
but
i think vimeo also offers a service
where you can do that so if you're
interested in self-distribution
vimeo and amazon i think are the best
platforms to do that on right now
and what type of video file is it
oh i i don't remember exactly what kind
of video file they require probably like
an mp4 or h.264
um
4k file ideally i think you can put
anything any any format you want i
believe
um it doesn't necessarily have to be 4k
and i'm not like a master at the self
distribution i've only done it once
so uh don't quote me on this but
but it's pretty simple and and amazon
definitely has instructions on how to do
it properly
with the text of the the subtitles is it
a text file or
how are you
i upload it i think so i think it is a
text file i'm not i'm not sure i i think
i remember actually going using youtube
i uploaded the movie to youtube
it youtube has an algorithm that
automatically scans every word and then
i copied all of that text from the
youtube
platform and then put that into the
amazon platform and then i just had to
sort of you know edit some of like the
spacing and alignment just to match but
there there are ways to figure it out
and google has been very good to me in
helping me through that process so
yeah
but but yeah i think it was like about a
year and a half since i went through
that and
i think i did the entire uh i set up the
entire self-distribution thing in about
a day or two really the hardest part was
just
really just uh
waiting for it to upload and then get
approved by by amazon
um and and there's also a good chance
that the entire uh means of uploading
has changed since then
i've been getting emails about changes
to their service and layout and i don't
really check it that often i kind of
figured you know 50 north is certainly a
movie that i made a long time ago i
don't intend on
searching for a whole new distribution
deal or anything so
i figured i'd just you know put it up on
amazon and let it live there
how do you think teaching others on
youtube has helped you to become a
better filmmaker i think it's sort of
forced me to come up with the most
efficient
method of doing certain things that i
can then just apply to my own filmmaking
and do it that much faster whereas
ordinarily i'd have to you know think
about how am i going to do this effect
or you know i i need to
experiment and premiere after effects
trying to figure out a certain you know
effects that i'm trying to do
doing these tutorials i
research the hell out of a certain topic
and then i just streamline it so that i
can
say it as succinctly
and
easy to understand as possible
so on some level it's also helped with
communication is you know i think if you
can
show other people how to do something
it helps you do it even
better and how has
either receiving um
reaction videos or getting comments
shaped your idea of audience feedback
if it has i'm sure it's it's happened
more subconsciously i i
i try to read as many comments as i can
i'm sure a lot of people are like don't
read the comments that's a bad idea but
i like reading them even even if they're
not great um
i i'm i'm pretty honest with myself and
i i have a feeling you know about the
type of content i'm putting out and
you know where it stands and with
everything else and
i i see tr some truth in some of the
mean comments sometimes i'm like they're
just me and that's ridiculous
and i love the support and i i love you
know
uh reading all the the positivity and
and most most of the comments are are
good like there's there's not too many
people that are just you know
all over everything and uh
uh hating what we do and if if they are
then it's just it's not for them and
that's okay
yeah i love it when people share about
their process or their life and you're
reading about someone
you know overseas and what they do and
to me that those are my favorite
comments
just to hear other people's process and
absolutely i i just released our first
making of video on our channel just uh
yesterday actually
um
i i mean i'm hugely inspired by david f
sandberg and i love that he does that on
his channel
so
you know i'm thinking well i love that
he does that i i should do that for
people that are watching our short films
uh you know why would i deprive them if
for anyone that wants to see it here it
is
so you know i put that together and it's
it's uh it's cool
are you excited to release your third
feature film val
i am it's uh
it's going to be a lot different than
the past uh assuming
the world is still closed down we were
planning on having a big premiere we had
to
cancel our wrap party because of
everything but um
you know that that aside
the actual making of it was an absolute
blast it was one of the best experiences
i've ever had making a movie it's a
horror fantasy kind of in the vein of
beetlejuice
and uh
yeah we plan on you know reaching out to
some of the same distributors that we've
worked with in the past and uh sort of
sending out the trailer and seeing what
happens seeing where we can uh
land a home for it
but i'm super excited it's it's a
different type of movie than than the
other two
what has it taught you about
storytelling this is the first movie
that a lot of people
that know me and worked on this movie
have said this is an actual movie
and i think what they meant by that is
storytelling storytelling-wise and
character-wise everything was just
it was it was just more it had a much
bigger punch all the
the protagonists were so much more
clearly defined and the antagonist was
clear
defined dimensional
um
the set pieces and the production design
we spent so much more time actually
looking for the right locations and
props and everything
so i think what this movie taught me was
to really just
it's the endless journey of paying
attention to as many little details as
you possibly can to make the best movie
and i think that that comes with time
because there are plenty of times in my
other first two films where i'm like oh
no this is good enough like the
production design it is what it is this
is what it looks like i'm happy with it
now i i don't really have that mindset
anymore i definitely spend a lot more
time focusing on everything
and
it's wonderful having a partner victoria
with me by my side helping and doing you
know doing a lot of the heavy lifting
and
shaping characters writing you know a
good portion of like female perspectives
for example
uh which i'm i'm oftentimes not too good
at
uh so
yeah i definitely learned a lot on this
movie and and i i hope uh i hope the
release is a successful one what's it
about it is about
it's hard to say what this is about
without actually giving away the ending
but it's sort of a supernatural
thriller horror comedy
very much like beetlejuice
about a criminal who's on the run
and he gets into an altercation with a
police officer at the very beginning and
he escapes and he breaks into a woman's
home
and holds her hostage and as the movie
goes on you realize that
his reality starts to sort of shift and
change and things aren't really as they
seem
and what inspired that
we were originally planning on making a
movie
a different movie that we wrote last
summer
and uh financing was actually we lost
the the budget for that movie the
financier actually pulled out
um
so i turned to victoria and i was like i
want to just make a movie i don't i just
want to make something that we don't
really rely on anyone else
let's come up with an idea
that
takes place in pretty much one location
with two actors primarily
and just
do the best we can and
she liked the idea after a
couple days of thinking about it i
turned to victoria and i was like what
about a movie about this
and she was like there's some potential
there
and then she offered a really cool
idea which
added
a
ton to the story we wrote it together in
about four months and
i think we're in production went into
production about
two months after that
so you're lucky you did it before the
pandemic we are so lucky honestly the
only reason i'm sane right now is
because we were able to shoot this movie
beginning of march and we rapped
probably about three days before
everything shut down
on set we were joking about
the the state of the world in like a
now very unfunny way but it was sort of
someone would cough and we'd be like oh
you have the corona and
it was sort of a loose joke on set now
looking back it's like no it's a real
thing
uh but we are all so thankful that we
got to
work one last time for a while
and um you know get this done before
everything closed down
so it was just perfect timing and and
you know i i think i don't think it's
it's a bad thing for the film i think
you know especially distribution
companies platforms are
because of such uncertain times it's
probably going to
um
it might even help you know i think
distribution companies are looking for
more material now
so so it might not be
that bad for for the film
do you have any adr or retakes
that you need to do for there's some
second unit stuff that we might have to
do
um there is one little piece that we
still have to shoot but
everything that we need to do from here
on out can be done
pretty safely
or even just hired out you know
uh to be done at on someone else's
time and just by themselves
sure they can mail you the audio file
exactly yeah do something yeah yeah can
you share what it was like for the two
months before production so you finished
the script and then you said you had
around two months before you it was
about two months since we finished yeah
and of course we're you know sort of
trying our hardest to just tighten up
the bolts of the script during that two
months pre-production phase but uh
you know that was pretty much just uh
meeting with dps directors of
photography and uh meeting with
actors making offers to actors that we
wanted to be in the film
um
locking our production insurance which
is one of the first things you do
getting your llc
in line so that you can do all of that
you know just pretty pretty standard uh
pre-production stuff
and then
we
went scouting for locations and the
location for this movie was very
important and we actually ended up
finding the perfect location in ojai
and um
we met with the owner of this property
and it was just a beautiful stunning
house and
we worked something out with her ended
up shooting the entire thing there
and uh
yeah to to raise the the financing for
the movie we had a sedan spark campaign
and then we also had some uh some
investors come on board that were
fans from electric love so they saw what
we could do with the previous film and
they invested some money into this one
um
i took the the little money that we had
made at that point of electric love and
put that into this one so it's literally
just you know the the circle
and we were able to come up with the
budget and um yeah shot over i believe
the entire shoot was 15 days
so it was tight
did the crew and cast stay at the house
in ohio or that was the fun part
everybody actually stayed in the same
house together it was basically just a
giant party for for 15 days in this
house in ohio
and uh
yeah it was just a lot of fun a lot of
great food and good times and um
yeah
do you set up these llc's yourself
victoria sort of spearheads the the
setting up of llc she does a lot of the
pre-production work um that's her
favorite part it's my least favorite
part
um
but yeah it's uh there's a couple
different ways to do it i think for val
we did it on legalzoom
and then for electric love we actually
went to
um a building downtown and and you know
filled out all the paperwork in person
um but yeah there's there's several
different ways to set up an llc and
yeah what's the significance of
guacamole
i love guacamole
[Laughter]
what's your best recipe
um sprinkling a little bit of the
pomegranate seeds
on top
of the uh of course avocado cilantro
red onion
a little bit of lime although i'm not i
could do with or without the lime
but the pomegranate seeds it's a nice
touch
it's a real nice touch